There are many different modes of raps such as gangsta rap, nerdcore hiphop,
and crunk. I mean there are three main ways within WebGL of repeating a
texture. These are called wrap modes. Here's a demo showing them in action. The
repeat mode is the one you're most likely to use. It simply repeats a texture
one after another. If you want to have things look continuous, such as water,
then the texture itself needs to be what is called seamless, where its edges
match up. If your texture is not seamless, one cheap way to tile it across the
plane is to set the wrap mode to be mirrored repeat. This concrete texture is
not seamless. I just grabbed a piece of an image on Wikimedia Commons. With
mirrored repeat on, the texture flips on each repetition. This is a bit easier
to see with the r texture. This wrap mode is not a great solution. It's often
clear that the texture is being flipped in this way. Still, it's better than
nothing. The third wrap mode is called clamp to edge. The drawback or feature
of this mode is that the pixels on the edge are used to fill in the area where
the texture does not appear. This is the default mode for wrapping, as it has
some advantages for filtering along the edges when the texture is not going to
be repeated. This code shows how to set each of the three wrap modes in 3JS.
The s and t axes essentially mean the u and v axes. You can in fact mix and
match these modes, repeating on one axis and clamping on the other. Now give
the demo a try yourself.